so stars are awesome and I don't mean
awesome in the oh my god wasn't the new
episode of Glee so awesome sense of the
word I mean proper or inspiring awesome
and seeing as I'm still stuck in my
little sister's old bedroom for the
moment I thought this is an appropriate
place to talk about stars and so that's
what I'm gonna do in this week's episode
of science fun science fun science a
science of fun yeah start you off if he
didn't already know stars are basically
ginormous super hot luminous balls of
plasma floating around in space and when
I say plasma yes
I do mean the same plasma that you find
inside of plasma screen TVs and plasma
lamps like this this is what stars are
made out of there's somewhere in the
region of between 200 to 400 billion
stars just in our Milky Way galaxy and
then there are over 170 billion galaxies
in our observable universe so if you do
math there are quite a lot of stars you
probably already know that stars don't
really look anything like this but what
you might not know is that stars don't
actually really look much like this
either there are two reasons as to why
stars from here on earth look like tiny
little sparkly specks of light in the
distance and the first reason is that
they are very distant so with our naked
fallible human eyes we can't really see
them very well and the second reason the
reason that we actually see stars
twinkling even though spoiler alert
stars don't actually twinkle is that
when the light from the star enters our
atmosphere it gets refracted or bent a
little bit and then we interpret that
bendy light as twinkling in reality
closer up stars actually look like this
and this time particular is a pretty
well known star it's a called the Sun
you might have heard of it it's a pretty
popular amongst us living organisms here
on earth gives us light and heat and
stops us from dying stuff like that and
even though the Sun is the nearest star
to us it's still about 93 million miles
away and it takes light about eight
minutes to get from the surface of the
Sun to the surface of Earth but
interestingly sunlight is actually much
older than you might think the light is
made right at the core of the Sun and
because the Sun is so friggin massive it
takes like about thirty thousand years
to get from the core to the surface
right now I'm being lit by the Sun and
I'm also being lit by a ceiling lamp so
the light on this side of my face
currently is about not
like a millisecond old but the light on
this side of my face is thirty thousand
years old science is awesome if you
wanted to you could fit about a million
earths inside of the Sun it's about 109
times the size of Earth or about that
big there's a picture but as big as the
Sun is it's still only a relatively
average-sized star in fact when we
compare it to the biggest star that we
know of in the universe a star called V
Y Sun is Majora's our Sun is about one
pixel big and then if you like you can
think about how big we are compared to
that pretty insignificant I think whew
my favorite thing about stars though is
what they actually do the light and heat
that they give off is pretty much just
an affectation of their main purpose
which is to take hydrogen the simplest
of the elements and build it into more
complicated elements like oxygen and
carbon and nitrogen it was Carl Sagan
who originally said that if you wish to
make an apple pie from scratch you must
first invent the universe because an
apple pie just like everything else on
earth is essentially just made out of
recycled atoms a star will spend it's
like making new elements in its core
until eventually it dies and explodes
and sends those elements out into space
and then those elements go into making
new things like planets and rocks and
plants and iPods and people the actual
elements that go into making me and you
and everything else on this planet were
formed in the furnaces of stars we are
literally made of star stuff and that's
one of my favorite things about science
is to be able to say something that
sounds as insane as that but to know
that it's actually true because it's
backed up by hard scientific evidence
anyway I hope you've had fun with the
science today and if you have any
suggestions for scientific topics that
you would like me to cover leave a
suggestion in the comments yo and I will
see you goodbye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool
[Applause]
[Music]